- Une ex-ambassadrice qui
en avait long à dire.
Devant les élus,
Marie Yovanovitch, a affirmé
que c'est à la demande de
Donald Trump lui-même qu'elle
a dû quitter l'Ukraine,
le printemps dernier.
Derrière des portes closes,
elle a affirmé qu'à son retour
aux États-Unis, son supérieur
lui aurait indiqué :
La diplomate de carrière,
assure avoir été poussée vers
la sortie, en raison
d'allégations non fondées
de la part de gens aux
motivations questionnables.
Une référence entre autres,
à Rudy Giuliani, l'avocat
personnel de Donald Trump.
Il a accusé Marie Yovanovitch
d'être biaisée, il se serait
même plaint qu'elle nuisait
à ses efforts pour convaincre
les autorités ukrainiennes
d'enquêter sur Joe Biden et
son fils.
Deux partenaires de M. Giuliani
auraient même fait pression sur
un élu américain pour que
l'ambassadrice soit relevée
de ses fonctions.
Ils ont été arrêtés hier pour
avoir violé les lois électorales
des États-Unis.
Ce sénateur démocrate se dit
troublé par ces révélations qui
semblent selon lui, prouver
l'existence d'un réseau de
diplomatie parrallèle en
Ukraine.
Le président Trump ne précise
pas pourquoi l'ancienne
ambassadrice a quitté son poste.
Soulignant qu'elle est peut être
une bonne personne, il laisse
entendre que le nouveau
président ukrainien ne
l'appréciait pas nécessairement.
Malgré la volonté du président
et de son adminsitration de
ne pas collaborer, l'enquête
menée par les démocrates se
poursuit. Plusieurs autres
diplomates, y compris
l'ambassadeur américain auprès
de l'Union européenne doivent
comparaître devant le Congrès
la semaine prochaine.
Ici, Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair, Radio-Canada, Washington